she's just so full of spirit and
everything she's resourceful
and they always talk they can't tell me
anything about boxing here
i don't know foxy and foxy satisfies
yourself yeah i know some of these girls
are all day
she does but you know you got to be
careful of course but one thing she
doesn't do is just
she don't go out there and get she don't
anyway whatever
yeah i don't judge those girls i don't
judge anybody i don't call i don't
qualify to judge anybody
no nobody should judge you period i'm
just muslim i mean that's why i do these
videos is like
once you hear the story of how these
people ended up where they're at
you you can't possibly do over an
[ __ ] so can i ask a question
again is there a benefit in the long run
or just to something that's
that's going to boost your business
where whatever whatever you're doing
no the reason i don't really make money
doing this because
not really because what i pay you i end
up
it adds up i'm paying you and about six
other people today
i'm to use maybe one or two of those so
that's a lot of money that's being spent
and when i travel it's much much more
and then sometimes i'm helping people
out you know but but it's got to be a
benefit for you to
post it and stuff like that for you
spending my time who knows that you're
just interested in
a network could pick it up one day or
something like that that really that
could lead to money but
for the time being it's a it's basically
a wash or a money losing proposition
usually
this is not the first time i've done
that i've done this with the midnight
mission i was there 22 months yeah i
mean i think these stories are good
for viewers to listen to and understand
how these people got in these situations
because i used to drive through
areas like this skid row and be like man
why don't these people just go get a job
why don't they just like get their [ __ ]
together why don't they stop putting you
know put down the crack pipe and just do
what they
and after hearing all these stories i
see it so differently now
yeah it's really like right now i'm
struggling trying to i'm blowing a
six-year relationship i haven't i don't
regularly talk to my mama's
my mom was my best friend but i don't
regularly talk to her
because she's just tired after 30 years
she's looking for me and this and that
the disappointment
and all that stuff in the setback she
she's just
she's tired of me but she does answer my
calls if i call her she'll
you know but but it's not the same man
my mom's 84.
you know but i think i think if the
audience or the you know the
society learns more about these stories
and how they happen
and pass it down to somebody that
potentially is going in this direction
no young parents or their children or
whatever protect their kids from the
they might change their mind you know
because i think things could
play out differently if people had more
understandings cracked up to be surreal
i mean
i would lie and say if i don't get any
any kind of enjoyment but
just for lack of terms biblically i'm in
the flesh
so what i'm doing is that whatever my
flesh desires i'm i'm do
you know what i mean if i have the
capacity or the finances or whatever to
do it
that's what i'm doing right now then
i'll when i get tired i go home
because i manage to just keep just by
this
[ __ ] the hair on my head to keep my
apartment and i live
in long beach i have a nice apartment
three blocks on the beach
but i'm just barely hanging on i'm
barely hanging on to that stuff and
those are material things
but i'm just i'm like a half a foot
on the street i might as well be on the
street because i'm not being a good
steward of what you know what god has
blessed me with so
where did i start what do you think the
origin of that is for you
it could be um
the self-destruct in the past look in
the past i i always feel like i wasn't
appreciated
i'm you know i'm i'm i if if i'm clean
or whatever
eve if i'm clean let me just say if i'm
clean
i'm the the best uncle the best brother
the best the best
you know uh boyfriend the best friend
but let me mess up one time and all bets
are off they treat me like [ __ ]
they treat me you know they they go so
hard on me
and they kind of like you know it's
almost like
and i don't count the good that i do or
anything like that but i'm like
you know that i'm like really you know
you know me
okay i mess up i messed up and i you
know stayed out two days with my
girlfriend let's
let's speak on a relationship i see it
out two days
so you're going characters assassinate
me on facebook you
you start talking [ __ ] around her son
that was there he's like 35.
so she's random raven talking [ __ ]
although she has the right to do so
because i heard her
and i disappointed her and i didn't call
so i i didn't call
but when i use in my am i using
career let's just say
i just hurt people and they just get so
hurt and disappointed i'm talking about
my my friends
my my employer uh and even uh you know
uh in 2015 i embarked on a on a business
which it was so sober living but i still
had to be followed by the state of
california it had to be all legal
you know i had to uh found my
organizations and things like that and i
had to wait for them to
so i i did that and god blessed me with
that and
in spite of my behavior my my sober
living was self-sufficient in one year
you know when my mother sold the house
she gave me the permission to run the
business out of her house but it was my
business
when she decided to sell the house
because i kept relapsing
it was 10 guys in there you know i
charged 650 a month yeah i mean well
let's just say 600 a month okay guys
it's a six
a six thousand dollar house it only
costs about two to
twenty five hundred to run the house you
know
just speaking in terms of finances and
money you know of course the maintenance
account and stuff like that but
i just with god you know i just
i think the crack addiction came from a
self-destructive streak that you had or
do you think the crack
led to the the crack addiction
came from just being vulnerable because
early on i used to just i used to you
know i should be a world there for the
longevity shipyard and every
week i would just get a quarter of
powder and get some beer
and me and my friends i would go around
the corner i'd live with my parents and
grab a quarterback
and we would just laugh and talk and
everything uh i lived in a predominantly
white neighborhood
sprinkled with filipinos or little
salons here or whatever
and a guy that i grew up with his name
is raymond gillespie
we called him junkie jr he he just came
over
one day just out of the blue and you
know he came over to kick back with us
or whatever and he said didn't you guys
know you could smoke this stuff
this was back in 83 and we were all so
vulnerable and we were like oh really
there was no resistance or anything
and he had the thing he had the the
baking soda and the
the vial to rock it up and each one of
us 20 years later
from that that one hit we were
[ __ ] addicted 20 years later
everybody in that whole
uh uh playhouse we were addicted
we were addicted so i've been struggling
with that off and on
i'll take a break i'll get my [ __ ]
together i'll start working or whatever
you know get my my my house in order you
know my buy me a nicer i love to drive
nice
and uh i don't know
a month later after i'm you know after
i'm starting to live life or whatever
i just destroy it i destroy it because
there's something about this life
i just like this i just something about
i don't know if it's the drama
i don't know if it's the the the women
that just are so irate and angry i don't
you know i i don't know what you know
what it is but i always
come back there's a girl on imperial and
avalon her name is coco she has one leg
and when i came back this time i can't i
had my bmw and stuff like that
i've
oh yeah that's my girl
2 000 i don't know 12.
i touched down over there hanging out
over i started hanging over in 2010
but in about 2000 let's just say 12 or
whatever
around thanksgiving she saw me i was
just re i was just
uh i was just a hazard just ready to you
know
i was just ready to just destroy
everything around me
um at that time i had a 99 camaro t-tops
it was beautiful you know anyway she
she literally just said
give me your keys
she was living with a white guy named uh
um
uh his name was mike in this van on
lanczyk
and imperial you're familiar with that
area i guess you've been over there
and his name is mike he's a hustler he
panhandles with
mike will go to some kind of he'll go to
the
the promenade and sit there with no
shoes on in an indian style position
and just sit there and people just get
money whatever
so what she did was that that really
that really uh i i mean inspire i mean
just made me love her is that because if
you know coco coco is a very angry
she's she's you know she's very loving
and everything her heart is full of love
and everything she'll give you
what you know but she's on the flip side
equally
she can hop on that one leg with a
hammer and hit you in the head with it
you know what i mean like yesterday i
was kicking out with him she was like
i gotta uh you know what marlon here i'm
gonna give you these two cigarettes
and i just need you to leave so i just
left i don't argue with her or anything
but when i met her around thanksgiving
she said give me your keys
it's just game tour she said i'm gonna
give you some brand new socks
and i need you to come over here i got a
whole gallon of water i need you to wash
your feet
and for some reason i just did it and
she said uh
she made a little place she made her
boyfriend or whoever
whoever that guy was to her wait outside
just wait outside
she made a space in the back you know a
van is really not that big but the
you know to sleep or whatever it's
pretty adequate or whatever she made a
little space for me to sleep
after i washed my feet and everything
she gave me the brand new socks
she gave me
i don't know if he's in this order but
she had a plate of
thanksgiving play and she
and i couldn't eat it all cause i was so
tired you know what i mean i was eating
and then i kind of fell asleep she gave
me a hit of crack cocaine
then what'd she do she gave me a little
cigarette i couldn't finish anything
and she gave me some um i just finished
one and she gave me a um
um a 211 something
but periodically throughout the day i
would sleep for like two and a half days
and she fed me periodically she said she
didn't go far
you know because she's a hustler she
hustles right there that's her
comfort zone she can make money right
there she probably won't go nowhere else
to make money right there because
everybody loves her you know what i'm
saying she's she's gonna make her
whatever she needs she's gonna get it
right there
and she shares a little bit she shares
but that's why i love her today i i
can't nobody can tell me anything about
her while i would entertain the
conversation
even though i know how she can get you
know i'm saying how
she can get who cares i i
every day i when i go when i touch down
on avalon imperial
if i'm you know gone for three or four
days if i get off that train or whatever
if i'm in my car i get out of my car
and i kiss her on the forehead every
single time we had sex one time
and it was beautiful
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
the most important thing that i've
learned most important lesson
the most important lesson that i've
learned is
i don't know if this is programming but
life is precious time waits for nobody
and i have to
learn not to take things that i possess
which is
material thing i'm not talking about
that i'm talking about relationships
i have to value those relationships and
not and not take them for granted
because
in an instant they still may love me
from a distance but in an
instant it's it at the end of the day
it's about family and friends man you
know regardless of what i
it's about relationships family and
friends and i miss that so much
i don't have it i i associate with i've
turned
my life in for people that really don't
give a [ __ ] about me
if i have a hundred dollars worth of
crack and she has been you know i'm
spending a little money
cigarettes whatever oh sure but when i
run out if i come over there and i'm
leaking
they don't give they really they don't
give a flying [ __ ] about me
and then my girl i've turned my life in
for this however i
don't ask me why i like a little bit of
this
but i cannot i'm not the one that can
get a little bit
and then go home and be cool for 30 40
days or whatever
you know and i might get you know hey
let me go over here and see what
so-and-so is doing this girl you know
the street whatever she is or whatever
and because i've had a good time with
her before a couple hours or hour
whatever it was
i enjoyed her so let me go do that again
or whatever i
i can't do it because i'm an addict
simple as that and i say i'm an addict
because once i start i can't stop
no off switch once i stop once i start i
can't stop
now i haven't been back to i haven't
been to prison since 09
but it used to it used to take me right
to prison
you know right to prison i will never go
to another program again because i can
direct the program probably restructure
it i know what to do
but you've been to ca meetings and stuff
like that oh of course i used to speak
yeah
yeah let's just speak i flaked out on my
sponsors and everything when i when i
was
getting that that that so we're living
together just talking help or
huh what do you what do you think about
talking about it all talking about what
just your problems your addictions all
this stuff um it kind of helps
but i don't know what the benefit of it
is that when i tell people that because
you know i lost my aunt in january like
just yesterday i spoke her name and i
started boohoon because
my mom's younger sister my auntie
i just you know so talking about this
stuff
and i said that to say bringing up
feelings
and within myself i don't know how i i
don't know how to be tore down
uh and and and therapeutically bring
myself back
up you know what i'm saying but i can't
cast my pearls before swine out here
i can't tell them my inter you know i'm
saying my my very
insensitive sensitive thoughts maybe a
couple of people will take the time to
listen
just a couple one or two but you can't
do it
you know like i said i've been in prison
a few times you can't sit up there
because everybody has a story
they don't want to hear that [ __ ]
because they once you start talking
about that
it brings up feelings that they're
trying to suppress
also i have to tell people that all the
time i mean come on
moles i've been molested too but i'm not
going to sit up here and every day i'm
not going to
you know i was molested when i was nine
years old you know i tell them get
get over it get [ __ ] over it if
you're gonna keep talking about it
start sharing with a lot of people so
you can help somebody with your story
god has helped you to overcome that
you're not going through it anymore it
happened
i mean that's not the reason why you you
understand
that's really not the reason why i use i
use
because i was um
i was vulnerable at the time when i was
partying it had nothing to do with my
childhood or anything
and i got caught off guard hey man
didn't you know you can smoke this
damn let me rock it up you had no idea
it's so addictive no and i was looking
at it
and look all of us little know we didn't
have any resistance it's a big
difference between cocaine and crap
no cocaine you know whitney houston said
that with oprah winfrey
let's get one thing straight i don't
smoke crack crackers whack i
smoke cocaine it's just a term it's just
the tournament they use
but i don't it's not cocaine anymore
however if you
put it if you just smoke it like in and
a zigzag and some
uh tobacco it's more it's that more of a
cocaine smell
you know you get that cocaine sensation
when you do it like that
oftentimes when you do it like i do it
you know you know you don't really get
you know it's just
really for the most part
it is absolutely just it is
it's grueling sure when you got 700
you can kick back do this do that do
that but even at that
it is grueling because you really really
you know what you want to do
but guess what once you partake or take
look
i'm going to go do this and do that but
i have to take one first so
once my mind is altered guess what all
my plans are scattered and [ __ ] i might
touch on that or get i don't know mark
you know
so that's why i have to have to just
sometimes when i
the material god gives me i just decided
man
i recite it so that i can you know i
could at least so i can give myself
another chance
because i understand the spiritual
aspect of this this is just the surface
a lot of people don't understand the
spiritual aspect of it
and there's a spiritual aspect of
everything that's going on around here
they don't understand people being
possessed they don't understand that
possess the deaf and dumb spirit you
know what i'm saying they and i
and i i'm spiritually discerned so i see
it and i've read the bible whatever and
i understand like
this is what he taught this is what the
bible talks about when they talk about
witchcraft
people don't understand that they don't
they're not talking about the wicked
witch of the west in the dungeon
and she's trolling up the potion right
however the similarity is the potion and
the smoke
what are we doing we're smoking you know
what i'm saying and we're looking at
that smoke
look we don't get man my pipe's not
hitting right i'm not getting the smoke
i don't go into it because they don't a
lot of people aren't
prepared or they don't even really want
to
they don't want to accept or process
what i have to say to
every now and then i might get somebody
look at that man
if you're looking at possession and
stuff like that spiritual
possession and stuff it's right here in
this in this area right here so once i
partake
i mean i'm just i'm man i'm fair game
for demonic activity as simple as that
mark i don't want to keep going there
but i'm i'm telling you i'm fair game
for demonic activity
you can be the nicest person mark cause
i already know you are
you probably have a little side to you
too i don't know i don't even care
i don't even care but you can be the
nicest person and that
when you're out there in this room
they still would flip it around and
throw you under the bus
anyway mark marlon thank you so much for
sharing your interesting story yeah
and well can i get into the story that
i'm about to tell
what's that moving 100 miles an hour
going straight to hell
out of control for the better years of
my life stealing
food from my kids and my wife but then
the lord can pull me out of the mire
because in my heart i got a real strong
desire to humbly serve him and bond
on my knees and look to heaven and say
lord lord please
deliver me from this life that i live in
so i can put my pride aside and be
forgiven
because in his word he says we're healed
by his stripes
[Music]
can you help me lord put down this
cocaine pipe
mark i'm about to lie for a long long
time he helped me run and escape from
reality
i was hiding and running for my people
because i truly didn't think i was equal
i went places that i never thought i'd
go this [ __ ]
i did things that i never thought i'd do
and hang out on the corner meet with me
men women whoever i took a lot of things
off of the shelf
because at the time i was only thinking
about myself i was blind but the lord
made me see
what i was doing
it really wasn't me
i thank you lord for very loving family
i didn't know but they always believed
in me
that's okay because the lord can bring
us through
i guarantee you he can do the same for
you all he wants is your trust and no
doubt
the rest the lord will work it all out
thank you lord for your mercy and your
grace
now these trials and tribulations i can
face no more running in and out of
prison since all night i haven't been
back
because now if i don't use i'm able to
make good sound decisions through my
faith is fervent and i'm focused
but now i have salvation and that's
worth living for
those who can hear i suggest that you
hear it you will fulfill the flesh if
you walk in the spirit
confusion delusion affliction addiction
man i'm not trying to push god or jesus
or nothing but give your life to christ
i guarantee you he will fix
it when i say that that's why i checked
my motives when i say that do i really
believe that
this is what he gave me but do i really
believe that jesus can fix it
because i prayed i've got on my knees
i've had i've been on prayer lines and
all of that stuff
but i still go to this destructive mode
and i always put my life on my mind
and i did that and i wanted to cap that
off with that
because um
you know i'm in bad shape i'm hurting
you know i i'm not
on my condition you know and um
i know you probably can't build me up
and you might be able to give me some
encouraging words
but i know that god can't let me just
say that
but do i really believe it you know a
lot of people say you know
of course i have faith and i don't have
doubt in god really
look at me all god gives me spiritual
things that i can edify
everybody else but but do i believe what
he's given me
to to to give to everybody you know what
i'm saying
do i believe the message that he has
given me to share with other people
do i believe that it can work for me do
where do i draw my strength from
i can't draw i can draw from within
because i
i always make resolutions and not a
decision i never make a decision like
you know what enough's enough i'm done
period and uh i'm sorry to be getting
emotional on you and stuff but
you know uh i'm in bad shape man
right now you know my life is
if you went to my place you'd be like
martin what the [ __ ]
i mean i have really nice appliances
really nice stuff three four blocks away
from the beach and i'm gonna say this
and i'm gonna be quiet
what is going on with you what is the
matter you know what i'm saying what is
the matter
what's going on you don't think it was
like the child molestation
or anything like that when you were
young i apparently that only happened
that happened okay i i don't know if you
ever heard it have you ever heard of the
group the fifth dimension
okay my my my dad's
sister used to sing background for them
anyway long story short she used to live
in englewood pretty nice house or
whatever
we went over there i went swimming and
stuff and there was this other guy
in the pool or whatever i can remember
he looked just like um
um jim kelly light-skinned
with the fro he looked just he got he
looked just like him i and uh
so we were swimming and everything and
uh we got out the pool i think we were
throwing the ball or something the ball
went back
so we get out the pool and there was a
um
like a garage or whatever so him and i
went in this garage
and he was just he had he had a heart on
he just made me touch made me put it in
my mouth and [ __ ] like that
and i was probably about eight
or nine and my dad was in there getting
high drinking or whatever and
associating with his sister
so uh i don't blame him for anything
you know if i mean me eight nine i'm
gonna periodically check on my kid you
know
that's what i'm gonna do especially
swimming i'm gonna have
you know i'm gonna know if he's you know
underwater or whatever i
have to periodically check on him but
for you to go through that as an
eight-year-old
can maybe i was like 11 or 12. or
whatever but
whatever the case it it can redirect the
the way you see yourself
for the rest of your life
possibly but i don't think that that
particular incident
is strong enough to to do that i think
more
so that i think it's more so that i
never thought my mom
really loved me uh like she loved my
sister my sister was a physician
but because i didn't get a college
degree like my sister
i was well on my way but everything i
was a disappointment
you know i'm saying even right at 54
i was 53 and 54. i won two ninety three
or three three on three tournaments me
and my my crew
you know in the uh you know uh
basketball you remember at staples you
shot all the basketball courts and [ __ ]
like that
yeah and the competitive pet not the
elite but then in the competitive
division
people practice all year to go that you
know to go to that event
and um and i said that to say that
um it's not like
you know i i i compete and i
and i uh enter in stuff like that
because that's what i do
you know i mean i play hoop you know
i've been cutting hair for 30 years this
is something i do i never
work at a shop or anything but a lot of
guys i can cut them under the table
but i'm not promoting myself whatever
but i'm just saying i've been doing that
and i'm really good at everything that i
do but i'm a person that
just doesn't have any longevity or
consistency at what i do
i i just you know so
everybody's on eggshells you know with
marlon
you know and especially man when i if i
mess up
oh my god i'm the biggest piece of [ __ ]
ever you know but when i'm sober
oh my god martin call martin ask marlon
you know my nieces and all that stuff
they want uncle marlon
let me [ __ ] up though bro let me mess up
i just need a little acceptance i'm 56
years old if i'm with my girlfriend
and i go home and i don't call you i'm
there for i have my own apartment
i'm old you know i'm a senior citizen
also you know what i'm saying
why would you care he's gone smoking
and being that i'm emotionally involved
with her man it just really pushes a
button
it it pushes a button and then it makes
me
want to be what they think i am okay i
just i went out
one night or whatever oh no there's
nothing i can do with you now
so everything who i am and everything
now you don't feel the same way about me
my mom don't feel the same way okay
you're disappointed but now you don't
feel you know so in my mind this is what
i think it is
what they think i am at that point
that's what i become
that's what i become because this is
what they think and i think it's a
controlled thing or i'm in bondage to
them
but if you think i'm that because i know
my intent every day
and i know what i want to do for you i
want
you know and it's not like i'm saying
i'm doing a whole bunch of stuff for you
it's just automatic i'm going to do this
for my girlfriend i'm going to get your
feet you know give you money even though
i can't spend like she spends
i still want to give her money to get
her her nails done her toes done
to get her hair done you know i cut her
hair but i mean her eye
whatever she wants to do and then once i
mess up
all of that is just you know i it is
it's just you know uh
um it doesn't count
nothing who martin really is does not
count
anyway mark that's all i have bro carlo
thank you so much
i needed that huh i swear i did
feels good i'm in bad shape man i'm
telling you
thanks for listening i probably bent
your ears back too much you look like
dumbo right now
but i really i really need i already
knew doing this i already knew coming in
here
that it was going to be some emotional
[ __ ] because i was going to just
you know just blab my but then there's
more
but a lot of people can relate i'm
there's more you know
doing this [ __ ] i'm scandless as [ __ ]
mark i'm a scandalous [ __ ] man
straight up
i have look i told i you know it's the
crack that does that it's not you
it's not merlin remember my song i said
um i forgot what what i was doing it
really wasn't me
thank you lord you know he showed me
that damn
this is not you and then i get
confirmation from people
man you know this ain't true this is
their issue they would say this is their
lifestyle
i said no you know what but i don't have
any i don't qualify to judge
what if i judge this is what i become
but guess what
this is what i become i become this
sit up here and talk about people and
everything and then all of a sudden you
shine in one day and then three days
later you're dull as your [ __ ]
dull last night
you don't have no money or nothing so
now you're asking people hey can i get
shorts on your cigarette
anyway whatever man that's that's what
it is it's just as petty as that but all
that pettiness
is serious yeah it's hard to stay on
track in it hard to stay on track
i don't have no excuses mark
what i with all that being said guess
what
this is what i've really learned is that
it starts with me and ends with me
if i want to change my surroundings or
my situation guess who it's up to
it's up to me i have choices
i guess when you ask me that's what i've
learned i have choices
i can remove myself i don't have to sit
in that
crap and and i can remove myself
but do i want to be removed you
understand what i mean
do i want that i want to stay here i
want this
anyway thank you man yeah i appreciate
you bro